[Musique]
il vous arrive de temps en temps de
faire des mauvais choix en fait dans les
coulisses avant de venir j'ai vu cette
carafe
je regarde dedans il n'y a pas d'eau
mais je vois que dedans il y avait un
objet je me suis dit tiens je le veux et
tu sais quoi
donc voilà je suis là j'ai pas trop
comment faire
bon après on est tous ensemble le 7 et
10 x c'est pas maman qui fait le top 6
mois donc je vais m'en sortir
on va essayer comme ça vous savez
parfois dans la vie il nous arrive de
faire des choix que l'on regrette
amèrement toute notre vie ça vous parle
d'accord on est en face super et nous
entretenons régulièrement des relations
assez complexe avec nos choix
oui faire ou ne pas faire manger ou pas
manger partir ou rester
survive ou vivre tarte au maroilles ou
quiche lorraine un câlin ou du chocolat
les loups de la cuisse aimé ou détesté
bref
les choix est parfois il est important
que nous puissions prendre du temps pour
prendre des choix il ya des gens qui
vous les connaissez probablement pas
vous bien entendu mais des gens que vous
connaissez qui attendent leur vie avant
de prendre des chemins important parce
qu'ils ont besoin de maîtriser le
maîtriser la situation d'avant le
sentiment que doivent rassembler toutes
les informations nécessaires pour être
sûr que la prise de décision va les
mener vers une réussite et ils attendent
et encore et on attend et puis parfois
il faut se lancer
et ça ça s'appelle de l'audace à
l'audace l'audace vous savez qu'on
confond souvent avec le courage on dit
souvent pro line array du courage bien
alors laissez moi juste faire une petite
parenthèse la différence entre l'audace
et le courage le courage c'est ce qui
nous permet de donner du sens aux
dangers qu est ce qui nous permet de
donner du sens aux événements négatifs
de la vie aux choses que vous subissez
oui parce que parfois la vie ne nous
fait pas cadeau
alors mesdames et messieurs soyez
rassurés la vigne fait cadeau à personne
même aux plus audacieux mais le courage
c'est cette capacité que nous avons de
pouvoir surmonter ces choses donner du
sens à l'imprévu et quand la vie parfois
ne nous sourit pas et bien c'est le
courage qui nous permet d'aller au bout
de la chose l'audace en revanche là
c'est tout autre chose
l'audace c'est vraiment aller chercher
la merde
l'audace c'est un joie ont choisi ont
choisi d'aller face au vent ont choisi
de prendre des risques
on va à l'encontre de toutes les
conventions va à l'encontre de toutes
les philosophies de tout ce que l'on
sait jusque là et on se dit on se lance
bon après pas n'importe comment bien
entendu parce qu'avant vous ne pensiez
que je fais l'apologie de l'audace à
tout va bien entendu il est important
d'évaluer il est important de rassembler
des informations
c'est clair il est important aussi de de
visualiser où l'on va de se faire des
scénarios
vous les connaissez ces scénarios savait
ce qu'on pourrait vendre à hollywood
tellement ils sont catastrophiques
en effet tous en général on s'imagine
dans les scénarios les plus
catastrophiques et hollywood serait prêt
à vous acheter très cher ce scénario et
vous savez ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la plupart du temps je ne se
réalisent jamais on s'attend au pire
et très souvent on oublie de s'attendre
au meilleur l'audacieux se lance alors
quand on fait preuve d'audace
quand on fait des choix il est important
aussi de se dire qu'à un moment donné
entre deux choix
ce qui compte c'est d'en choisir un
ajustement et ça s'appelle le pouvoir de
la résolution laissez moi vous expliquer
brièvement
imaginez qu'on vous offre une pomme et
quel côté vous avez un panier de pommes
les mêmes pomme elles sont toutes vertes
et bien la différence sera la suivante
si vous prenez une pomme que vous l'avez
choisie ou qu on vous en offre une vous
aurez le sentiment que la pomme que vous
avez choisie sera la meilleure parce que
vous l'avez choisi alors allé à tokyo ou
années à new york
on se torture pour savoir où c'est qu'on
venait en vacances l'année prochaine on
ne sait pas trop et alors les semaines
passent les jours passent les mois
passent et on sait toujours pas jusqu'au
moment où on a pris une résolution
je vais à tokyo et vous savez ce qui est
magique c'est qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez pris la décision de partir à
tokyo vous êtes dans la capacité de vous
imaginer en vacances c'est là où le
cerveau est capable de vous permettre
d'imaginer vos vacances vous pouvez
planifier quelque chose alors bien
entendu ce n'est pas toujours aussi
simple
bien entendu
ce que je vous dis là c'est juste
simplifier un principe qui peut bien
entendu être complexe alors parfois on
fait des choix on avance et on se rend
compte que ça ne marche pas alors on
fait appel à ce qu'on appelle la
persévérance ah oui parce que on ne
réussit pas tout du premier coup
ça serait quand même là alors en
revanche oui là j'ai réussi du premier
coup
j'ai mis ma main du premier coup voilà
la persévérance et vous savez à partir
du moment où la persévérance devient
douloureuse bon au fond c'est pas si
grave que ça parce que on a eu des
sportifs aujourd'hui on a des gens qui
vous a augmenté de merveilleuses
histoires à succès et bien entendu
souvent la récompense devient après un
petit peu tout france quand même un
petit peu mais après quand cette
souffrance devient vraiment trop forte
quand on commence à perdre des amis
quand on commence en effet à perdre tout
ce que nous avions autour de nous et que
ça nous fasse souffrir au point de
perdre même la raison ça s'appelle
l'obstination
elle est là la différence entre la
persévérance et l'obstination si la
cause est bonne c'est la persévérance
si la cause est mauvaise c'est
l'obstination
alors quand nous devons agir
nous faisons un choix et que nous devons
agir
nous devons aussi prendre conscience de
certaines choses mais si vous vous
expliquer pendant douze ans j'ai vécu
aux pays bas personne n'est parfait nous
en pays bas sa marque
ça marque à vie j'ai fait ma vie là-bas
et aux pays-bas vous avez la zélande à
ce super la mer du nord et beaucoup de
gens ont dévoyé et j'ai eu l'opportunité
de faire de la voile pour une première
fois
et vous savez quand vous faites de la
voile pour une première fois il ya
toujours un instructeur qui vient vous
expliquer ce qu'il faut faire
sauf que il avait aussi oublié
d'expliquer ce qui ne fallait pas faire
j'explique moi je suis bon élève
le skipper m'explique un moment donné
michel toi tu prends la barre tu vas la
barre et une à tout droit il ya le
combat juste devant toi je suis le
compas rien d'autre à faire cool génial
on est à plusieurs sur le bateau alors
imaginez un peu le temps est beau il
fait chaud
la mer est d'huile le vent est favorable
on est parti pour une merveilleuse
journée sur la mer du nord
sauf que bien entendu ça aurait été trop
beau si si ça pouvait aller comme ça
jusqu'au bout soudain le vent tourne
c'est ce qui se passe sur un voilier
convent tournée que vous tenez la barre
juste tenir la barre des personnes qui
font de la voile savez ce que c'est que
de prendre du roulis c'est qu'à un
moment donné le bateau signer à prendre
du roulis pencher de plus en plus fort
moi je suis à la barre je comprends rien
je fais tout ce qu'on m'a demandé un je
suis cap
le skipper qui sort de la cabine il me
pousse une grande
il prend la barre il commence à crier à
tout l'équipage
il faut changer les voiles de position
oui on savait pas et donc en effet tout
le monde sait à fait intérêt à changer
les voiles de position pour changer
l'angle de ses voiles et le bateau s'est
progressivement redressée nous avons pu
continuer de course
alors bien entendu nous avons dévié jeu
pas bien grave
nous avons dévié mais nous étions ça
réchauffe imaginer revenir à la nage
dans la mer du nord s'est plutôt blabla
pas gagné ce qui est intéressant dans
cette histoire c'est que la vie m'avait
offerte une merveilleuse métaphore vous
connaissez l'expression être capitaine
du navire est capitaine de sa propre vie
je n'ai compris voilà
c'est tout simplement que nous pouvons
en effet parfois perdre du temps à
pester sur les éléments posés des
questions qu'elles nous n'aurons jamais
aucune réponse
mais pourquoi le vent tourner ça allait
si bien
mais pourquoi le courant ont changé
c'était parfait je comprends pas on
était vraiment sous la route il ya tout
a bougé alors ces questions qu'on se
pose parfois vous savez je les reconnais
regarder pourquoi moi ouais on en phase
ou qu'est-ce que j'ai fait aux cieux
pour mériter ça comme si en fait la vie
où on devait mérité ou pas hein
alors pourquoi moi laissez moi vous
expliquer une chose vous n'aurez jamais
la réponse
bon c'est déjà sympa je vous offre ces
cadeaux ne vous posez plus de questions
vous n'aurez jamais la réponse parce que
ce n'est pas juste pourquoi vous c'est
tout le monde d'accord on est tous à la
même enseigne
on est tous égaux ce niveau là pourquoi
moi c'est vous juste pas la bonne
question
posez-vous juste les questions qui vont
vous permettre d'agir qui vous permettre
de changer les voiles de position alors
faut que je prenne une décision
je peux faire plusieurs choses je peux
prendre plusieurs décisions je peux
venir là dans la salle et vous demander
de m'aider mais j'ai peur d'avoir mal
oui parce que will peur d'avoir mal ça
aussi c'est ce qui fait qu'on veut
maîtriser aussi qu'on a peur de prendre
des décisions c'est qu'on a peur d'avoir
mal
là oui on n'est pas masochiste quand
même on n'aime pas échouer
enfin pas tous on n'aime pas avoir mal
aux jeux
piqué quelque chose en amérique du sud
et en inde
il est des chasseurs qui capture les
sages à l'aide de pièges fait de noix de
coco avec une petite ouverture et
donnent un autre qu ils y mettent un
fruit ou une firme friandises lesage
s'approche mais la main dedans prend la
friandise et ne la lâchera jamais à un
point que quand le chasseur viendra mais
préférera mourir que de lâcher prise
la chip reese la chip reese qu'est-ce
que ça peut bien vouloir dire on entend
tellement parler lâcher prise et bien
c'est très simple c'est arrivé à se dire
que vous n'achetez plus d'importance à
quelque chose qui vous touche
ça veut dire que la chose qui vous
touche en ce moment n'a plus
d'importance
regardez comment ça se passe la maman
tient cet objet que j'ai vu c'est pour
ça qu'il peut plus en sortir
vous avez entendu maintenant puisque
j'ai lâché prise je peux prendre du
recul je peux le voir et je peux
observer les choses sous d'autres angles
et me dire qu'il ya peut-être d'autres
possibilités pour arriver à prendre ce
que je rêve toujours voulu prendre en
deux cartes 3g la main mon objectif est
de l'appréhender différemment elle me
dire ah mais oui vous savez quoi
c'est important qu'est ce qui fait que
les enfants apprennent plus vite que
nous mesdames et messieurs parce qu'ils
sont enfants donc mon expression
mauvaise réponse
tout simplement parce qu'ils ne savent
pas que c'est impossible parce qu'un
enfant n'est pas encore formaté par tu
ne peux pas c'est pas possible tu n'es
pas capable
tu n'y arriveras pas parce qu'un enfant
crois que c'est possible
lorsqu'un enfant rêve et pense que son
rêve peut se réaliser
mesdames et messieurs qu'en est-il de
l'enfant qui est en vous j'ai vu
plusieurs jeunes ici dans la salle ça
fait chaud au coeur et chers jeunes
demoiselles les jeunes hommes ne tuez
pas l'enfant qui est en vous continuer à
garder cet enfant parce que c'est lui
qui vous permettra de faire preuve
d'audace dans la vie par une audace
folle parce que bien entendu quand je
l'expliquais nous devons rassembler des
éléments qui nous permettent de savoir
si ce que l'on va faire
va plutôt avoir de la chance de réussir
ou pas la chance ah oui vous savez c'est
audacieux les énerve
il nous énerve c'est audacieux oui parce
que ils ont plus de chance que les
autres ils font de meilleures rencontres
que les autres ils voyagent ils ont
meilleurs résultats qui sont optimistes
et quand il échoue les essais il
recommence fin il agace sur tout ce qui
ne s'est jamais rien et je vais ce qui
se passe quand lee mobilis tu vois un
audacieuse planter leurs lits mobilis la
direccte y faire
je savais l'audace c'est dangereux ou
alors il dit ouais ça j'en étais sûr je
pouvais le dire tout ce qu'il a fait là
s'en servent à rien puis retourne voir
sa série préférée
en général les immobilise savent bien
pointer les audacieux du doigt et puis
après les critiques et quand ils ont du
succès mesdames et messieurs vous êtes
tous ici présents et tous ceux qui nous
regardent en rediffusion les héros de
votre propre vie
parce que tous à un moment de votre vie
vous avez fait preuve et de courage et
d'audace
parce que si vous êtes là aujourd'hui
comme vous êtes vous est le fruit de ce
que vous avez vécu vous est le fruit de
vos choix
même les mauvais parce qu'être audacieux
c'est aussi prendre le risque bien
entendu d'échouer et c'est aussi le
risque de réussir et puis j'ai envie de
dire pour conclusion si au fond les
chèques
c'était par d'abandonner ou de ne pas
essayer
je remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et